hello and welcome to this video playing
courtier crow Tina not Cortina playing
um Ellicott's
okay I have to be cautious I tend to
[Music]
screw up move orders
[Music]
Bishop III night before
c5 queen Eve
you
three
yeah I tend to make mistakes in with the
move water sometimes it's a tricky
tricky thing in blitz chess but it's
it's okay it's okay
don't I don't think I did anything wrong
and okay maybe I did
that's something that you usually
[Music]
don't allow or maybe I should let Queen
City to
you
it's a bit annoying really
allowing the stuff
okay
you
I'm a bit surprised that he takes time
there okay now we has taken a I've got
this somewhat odd porn on III but is it
really a big problem I don't I don't
think so
I've got rook a to e1 and night 95 is
one-one idea there
he very confidently brought out the
Queen to g5 but
is it all that is it all that scary okay
but should be for maybe
the glues there but still
minam on d5 a million times and I'd like
to kick the night back yeah now you have
to go to a six with black eeeh isn't
that a bit of a concession
oh really now that's a good structure
for me I take here
and I have a little trick I'm going to
try this maybe he goes to h5f route 85
which is funky
it's it's even good here right
let's do it it's just a very very
aesthetic move so let's do it
yeah it doesn't help you it doesn't help
you
there was a dead that idea with night
before and and and that that was wrong I
think okay so getting somewhere with my
rating finally I just I just I think I
really should be closer to 2600 and I'm
getting them anyway so um let's have a
quick look here this is a theoretical
position and I am not quite certain
maybe I have to play
I think p3 is right maybe Queen d2 here
first I'm not really aware of this move
maybe I don't need to prevent it I mean
the engine just loves my position after
Queen d2 and I kind of agree once I saw
it it looked fine I mean this is not
really a problem and in particular if
the knight comes to f4 that makes a lot
of sense and the F file and so on I
think quite good I actually think that
Queen g5 is not right I think this is
wrongly placed down I'm so surprised how
much the engine disdains black position
really hates black
and there are probably too many things
going on there is 9595 queen f2
sometimes like a queen f2 queen g3
threatening h3 many liabilities and the
Knights looking
Nanook downright silly and once there's
a pawn here that night makes little
sense but this is this is probably
really wrong okay 94 just wins
okay then I'm stupid I'm stupid to go I
just
this is unprotected this is unprotected
yeah it's it's 101 oh wow yeah wins wins
an exchange and with a good position
okay
yeah he went c6 a3 and now for better or
worse and I have to go or worth worth 96
you have to do this is awful
simply awful at age three yeah Bishop a5
Bishop c8 you have to play to get out of
out of any trouble yeah and can you just
toast it's too much G form yeah I know
I'm winning winning this with you can
this this looks this looks very
aesthetic yeah you've got five pieces on
the fifth rank with two rooks that's
really something else
okay guys thanks for watching